hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play condemn
now we are pursuing a man who's devious
in his ways I don't know what the point
is of this guy oh look another another
dying bird oh boy don't worry I'll take
care yeah not stuff you in my back
pocket until I get you home pinata wall
Kodama freaky freak Oh what the hell
there's nothing here nothing here
nothing hair don't need that oh I get it
climb all the way over that chain sorry
oh [ __ ] hell yeah I am you should
know thanks to you Oh
stay down your deck god damn oh man I'm
so not ready for that I'm not used to
there being any sort of like oh man yeah
copy like completely awesome no I just
come on let me snap you snap your neck
grab it slap ow throw the towel man God
anyway I'm moving on from that
alright not ready for it not ready at
all
I should have known something was up
when he went over that that little lady
be chained in such a weird way okay
better now better now who by saving
cannot save now why can I not save now
why can't I save that way that that is
not oh there we go huh well that's one
way to start an episode god damn are
these people dead already
I didn't kill them oh there was another
hell thing right here
Saudi pop hmm Oh a dead bird how loverly
please give me that someone's killing
someone down here oh look it's the
subway to the nightmare land oh it's my
favorite can I ride on you that's my
pickup line of course hey girl can I
ride I know okay so he got on here why
can't I get on here jump down those
probably bird over there and jump back
up nope ah ain't gonna happen no give me
on no don't leave without me
oh that's all okay it's not what I'm
supposed to do I just ripped that off
its handle cuz I'm so strong all those
bolts didn't stand a chance from my
massive muscles yeah what is in this
morning
kaboosh LeBouf what the hell oh my what
what's that okay what the hell is going
on ah ah oh no what did I bug the game
am I supposed to be inside there right
now or what
I think I'm I supposed to be in there
I'm pretty sure that oh wait maybe oh
hello hi okay maybe not skits um nope
nope no no guess what the bad choice for
you buddy
haha oh holy hell oh that's not good
this this is not good this is less than
good oh oh yeah radical man I'm skating
along huh hi hey what are you gonna save
me save me buddy please please pretty
please
ahh
what the hell how did that how did that
do that I don't know things seem to be
things seem to be a little off kilter
there I'm not sure what was going on I
was weird anyway okay yeah I was that
lost their train must topic the next
platform
is there another dead bird that I'm
tracking I'm pretty sure that's tool
that I'm using is not meant to track
dead birds I'm pretty sure that its main
design is not tracking difference
yeah keep fighting each other I like
that I know what
oh there it is uh ah lovely lovely now
so lovely I wonder why I can't just pull
that out at random points because it
would be helpful to find birds but it
only seems to be used for finding
certain birds
what the hell what was that
well whatever it is I guess I'm gonna go
find out goddamn oh sure deivis oh my oh
my no you die from that number Gary then
okey-dokey
he's uh dead now
ooh five she'll be like me thank you
very much
something seems slightly off with the
sound I don't know what okay someone
gonna pop out on me oh I knew it I'm
gonna jab right in your head
headshot yeah this taser takes care of
those guys pretty easily
anybody out there
oh this looks good
Oh ion that's right in the head again
oh I'm a no reticle whoa
no no no no aah - yeah whoa
what have I do - laughs yeah whoa whoa
whoa whoa
I saw something shadow or something
shovel required oh yeah because the
shovel is the ultimate keypad hacking
tool I forgot about that
oh look another for an epic shoveling
action
I'm not sure where I am going hello
anybody down there ah shovel I see it
but I got so many bullets fine fine
Godley okay I didn't want you all to
realize that I'm sprinting right now
taser Oh what was that nope
oh yeah okay nope yeah that's what I
thought you shovel punk yeah not even at
the keypad just around the keypad tends
to work the shovel is a very very
effective tool
yep Punk oh man oh I get it
Oh Oh it cuts power oh that makes so
much more sense than that
oh I get it now that's why it works I
never understood that before but now I
do
and it's still kind of silly because I
think that would have a sale place
myself is a fail-safe
oh this looks good
Oh head shout soos what drug are these
guys taking that's making them all
freaky like this what under seriously I
can't okay there we go
hi hi come back here come back really I
can't jump down there come back here
hello hello
hi Simon I must be AUSA's returned home
guess he's done with nightmare land
let me guess another dead bird around
here
that sounds good
now it's getting a little atmosphere ick
I kind of wish I had my shotgun again
what nothing
I really wish I had my shotgun there's
the subway car for clues
oh I connected Thomas transfer data when
ready oh I get it lady like blood or
something that I'm looking for nothing
here
organic evidence clothes bright purple
well how about that
ah ha ah ha ha ha wait I saw it ah ha ha
ha ha click click give me that
yeah get me a sack are you yeah yeah
yeah get a read on the brats too smudged
get a sample though he's scared and
sweating like a horse sounds good to me
a sample
collect slurp slurp slurp cuz I just
carry these on my person Hank I'm
initiating a DNA profile on the sample
this will take a while can you keep
yourself busy until that par har-har-har
you're so funny lady so funny how do I
get out oh what uh whoa what a car you
got sledge hammer whatever you are can I
get out now I want to fight this guy
I've got a shovel yeah that's right
that's what I thought whoa lady
I know there are lady crazies crazy
ladies
he's hablen now
come on bring it bring it big guy I want
to fight you I want to fight you stop
making out behind that pillar and fight
me really did you bug out did you really
get stuck really really no really really
now really did you really really really
really really oh I get it
whoops I'm an idiot nevermind I'm stupid
I'm stupid
here we go I'm barely have enough time
to fight this guy come on bring it bring
it big guy
once you got let me guess my taser won't
do nothin to you hey get out here oh no
oh give it up give me do you oh thank
you now as I walk whoops try it oh yeah
no pound do little dance a punch ah yay
owns you so hard car I'm the best I'm
the best ever was about that lady but
you a little too crazy looking not that
I not are you ain't prettier nothing but
well
Wow yes okay is there anything else over
there Hank
never know when there's a dead birdie I
want to collect what a seriously what
are these guys taking that is turning
them into vampire freaks crawly creepy
crawly vampire people even oh hello
orange guy oh oh he changed his clothes
interesting close the door
toilet cabinet all right I am actually
all out of time thank that thank you
thing talking thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye